millones de roedores por doquier en la
capital del mundo esta plaga pasea por
los parques las calles el metro e
incluso por los hogares de los
habitantes de la ciudad las autoridades
neoyorquinas toman medidas para
controlarlos la lucha contra el crimen
la lucha contra la desigualdad la lucha
contra las ratas es algo en lo que
estamos entre dos Mientras seguimos
haciendo de esta ciudad una ciudad
habitable todos los que me conocen Saben
una cosa odio las ratas las ratas no
tienen lugar en esta ciudad y vamos a
utilizar todos los métodos necesarios
para hacerlo para que no perjudiquen a
las familias y a nuestra calidad de vida
el alcalde decidió crear el cargo de un
director de mitigación de roedores el
aviso de la oferta de empleo decía con
Sarcasmo se necesita una persona con una
actitud de espadachín humor astuto y un
aura general de maldad los avistamientos
de ratas se han disparado un 71% en los
últimos dos años según el departamento
de saneamiento de la ciudad las ratas no
dirigen ciudad nosotros lo hacemos la
presencia exponencial de estos animales
se deben en gran medida a la pandemia ya
que los restaurantes pudieron servir
como una medida temporal en mesas en las
aceras este octubre las autoridades
decidieron poner un freno e impusieron
medidas para que la gente no deje basura
en las calles y así evitar que los
roedores lleguen según la creencia
popular hay una rata por cada habitante
de Nueva York es decir unas 8,8 millones
Pero según un estudio de 2014 la
población de roedores es de 2 millones